Over the past two years,
how many times have you heard
that the times have changed
or about the new normal?
There’s no shortage of opinions
about whether remote work
is for the better
or spells destruction for our businesses.
Reed Hastings, CEO of Netflix, said,
"I don't see any positives,"
whereas Suresh Kumar, CTO of Walmart,
said, "We haven't just coped.
We've actually thrived."
But what does the research say?
How can we know, not just think,
that hybrid working actually works?
There are so many questions.
What's the right balance of work from home
versus work from the office?
And who gets to decide?
Is it managers, is it the employees?
Is it both?
How long can a given employee actually
remain productive working from home?
Is there a limit?
And who gets to work in each way?
What should it be based on
in terms of criteria?
Should it be based on seniority,
task, personal situation?
The list goes on and on.
So many questions and unfortunately,
no simple answers.
The reason these questions
are so hard to answer
is because we're thinking about hybrid
work design as a single problem.
One problem to solve, when in fact,
it's actually three different ones.
The first problem is
are we able to effectively deliver
on our stakeholder commitments?
This is otherwise known
as the effectiveness debate.
The second is will we be able to attract
and retain the talent that we need?
This is the staffing discussion.
And the third is can we maintain
or even cultivate, nurture, our culture?
This is the talk about social fabric.
Let's take a minute to highlight
the challenges inherent in each one.
I've been working with a range
of organizations over the past two years,
helping them determine what
their future of work should look like.
Now, I'm not here
to make a broad statement
that remote work is
or is not universally good.
I think we're all
smart enough here to know
that nothing works all of the time.
I am, however, here to warn you
that we need to be wary of our data.
Let me give you a couple of examples.
Many people point to their organization's
effectiveness during COVID
as proof that they're actually
good at remote work.
Now it is proof that remote can work,
but not that it necessarily will.
COVID was a massive social experiment
with unique conditions.
Most organizations dealt with it
by cutting the fat
and becoming laser-focused
on short-term efficiency.
In effect, we were productive
because we were in survival mode.
But the question we have to ask
is whether that's sustainable.
Data shows around the world
that people's working hours
have increased,
and many say that they
actually find it harder
to delineate work-life boundaries.
Data also shows that the experience
wasn't the same for everyone.
With “The Economist” data showing
that parents of school-aged children
experienced much greater stress
than many others.
And data from Microsoft shows
that it's actually even changing the way
in which we work,
with people working more hours
but less collaboratively.
The question of whether
we can effectively work remotely
needs a contextual answer.
Contextual based on the people
who are doing the work
and the tasks that they're
trying to accomplish.
Remember, one size fits none,
and we need to think
about the sustainability
of our effectiveness.
Now, when it comes
to the staffing discussion,
ask anyone who has recently
been involved with hiring.
The most common question that recruiters
are being asked these days:
"What is your flexible-work policy?"
In effect, we’re facing
the same escalation of perks
popularized by tech companies
during the boom.
Do you have a barista pulling
the perfect flat white in the lobby?
Do you have nap pods?
A ball pit? A slide?
What about on-site daycare, right?
So then instead of work from home,
we actually bring home into work.
Your current or potential future employees
are now weighing your hybrid work policy
as a key criteria in their decision
of where they want to work.
And that is the crux
of this staffing challenge.
What you need to recognize
is that the comparison isn't actually
between work from home and office work.
Instead, it's really between
the perception of work from home
versus the perception
of work from the office.
And you need to reclaim that narrative.
Let me give you a couple of examples.
The first is what I call
the recovered commute.
Many people have told me,
"I've saved so much time
now that I don't have to commute."
My challenge to them?
What did you actually do
during your commute times?
Maybe you read, maybe you caught up
on calls or emails,
maybe you just use it
as time to decompress.
Personally, I used to get an hour
to shake off a particularly rough,
annoying, frustrating day
before I got home.
Now it takes me exactly six seconds
to be immersed in my family upstairs.
Another example, the after-meeting
postmortem debrief over a coffee, right?
We use that to do some
relationship repair,
maybe to do some collective sense-making.
The most important thing to recognize here
is that what matters most
is the experience,
not just what the policy is.
We need to reclaim the narrative to help
ensure that everybody recognizes
what a given approach
either buys or loses for them.
And this brings us to the social fabric.
Think about what happened
when you joined your organization.
You probably went to orientation.
Maybe you looked around,
you talked to some people, you observed
and you learned
what it's like to work here.
Why does that matter?
Well, because our research
shows reductions in things
like psychological safety and trust,
changes to power dynamics,
increased feelings
of isolation and loneliness
when we are working
remote from one another.
Importantly, all of these
shape our cultures
and make this conversation
even more difficult.
And on top of that,
social systems are dynamic,
emerging, evolving human systems.
Now, I'm going to be honest,
I don't have the answer to this.
And honestly, anybody
who tells you they do,
they're trying to sell you something.
We do know about different
approaches to building
and establishing culture
in these contexts.
What we have to recognize is they operate
in ways that may not be the same
as the way we built culture
when we were face to face.
What we have to remember here
is that organizational culture
is a long game.
What we do right now affects
the social fabric of our organizations
and will have repercussions down the line.
So when it comes to the social fabric,
we need to think not only about today,
but about tomorrow, next month,
maybe even next year.
I hope you recognize that these are three
distinct conversations
that are also not fully independent.
We also have to recognize
what makes this challenging
is that they are almost
ideologically different positions
about what creates value
in your organization.
Is it about the output
of what you produce?
Is it about the people
in that organization
or something in the ether, the culture?
The first most important step
is getting these issues on the table,
having an open conversation.
And this is far from easy.
But if you find yourself in disagreement
with somebody over these issues,
whether it's a boss, a subordinate
or your leadership,
I challenge you, ask yourself,
do you really disagree
on how to create effectiveness,
deal with staffing or the culture
of the organization?
Or is it maybe just that you have
slightly different prioritization
of those three different parts
of the whole hybridity conversation?